شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى هذه
الساعه الاخباريه من تغطيتنا المتواصله
لتطورات الاوضاع الدراماتيكيه في السودان
اذ فيما تستمر الاشتباكات لليوم الثالث
على التوالي اكد الجيش ان جميع مقرات
القياده العامه ما زالت تحت السيطره رغم
الاشتباكات الضاريه التي تدور منذ ساعات
لكن في المقابل ما تزال قوات الدعم السريع
تؤكد سيطرتها على مقرات داخل القياده
العامه هذا فيما تاكد استيلاء قوات الدعم
السريع على مطار مروي العسكري بحسب
المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني في تصريحاته
للعربيه حيث تعهد باستعادته في اقرب وقت
ممكن
وبيئه الاحداث التي تحدث منذ الاول من امس
اشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحامات بعدد من
المقرات العسكريه نحن نتصدى لهذه
المحاولات
واضافه الى ان هنالك عمليات قنص واستهداف
لضباطنا وجنودنا لذلك تم جرت محاولات
لاعتقاد القبض على افرادنا ضباطنا
اذا عرفوه الى مواقعهم مواقع عملهم
الرسميه تم
القبض على واقول اما القبض على العديد من
الضباط الذين هم دارسون في دور
مثلا قيمه على الاستخبارات او ضباط توجهوا
الى مواقع عملهم في الصباح تم اعتقالهم
واعتبارهم جوع بشريه في مقرات مليشياء
الدعم السريع
جدا اقل عده بكثير من اليوم
الاول نحن نعصر عمليات
نا مرحله في التصدي لمحاولاتهم اقتحام بعض
المواقع مقرات القوات المسلحه في محيط
القياده العامه لجميع مقرات القياده
العامه هي الان تحت يد مسيطره القياده الع
كما نفى العميد نبيل عبد الله الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني للعربي ادعاءات قوات الدعم
السريع بالسيطره على اجزاء من مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه والقصر
الجمهوري وقصر الضيافه نؤكد انه لا صح
اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي مقرات القياده العامه ولا
على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر الجمهوري
هذه التهذيب مضلله الامر الثاني نحن نؤكد
اننا في القوات المسلحه لاننا قوات محترفه
وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما بجميع
قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات نحن
نتقيد تماما
بمقررات القانون الدولي الانساني قانون
النزاعات المسلحه في هذا النزاع المسلح
وفي المقابل رد يوسف عزت المستشار
والسياسي لقائد القوات الدعم السريع على
تصريحات الناطق باسم الجيش مؤكدا للعربيه
سيطره الدعم السريع على القصر الجمهوري
ومقرات القياده العامه نحن نسيطر على
القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر على كل المغاره
المتواجده على طول شارع
نحن نسيطر على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم
والكباري كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه نحن
فقط عبر هذه القناه نطمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على
مواطنين او ينهب وممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه
رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل
المواطنين في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم
من المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها
[موسيقى]
هذا وتتواصل للشبكات في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويقع مقر القياده العامه في المنطقه
الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه
كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم الدولي كما
يتواجد بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات
البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات الجويه ويعد
مقر القياده العامه مركزا مهما وحساسا
بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني ويستمر
اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع تداول
اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله في القتال
خلوها قبضناها
زي ما قعدت تقولوا اسعى ربطكم في فتيلنا
كويس الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
رباط الدعم السريع في قبضه القوات المسلحه
بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله لاي مليجه
الرساله اللي ايليشيا
هذا واصدر رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان قرارا بحل
الدعم السريع واعلانه قوه متمرده على
الدوله وذلك بحسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه كما اكدت الخارجيه ان كل
الوساطات الوطنيه لدمج الدعم السريع
بالجيش قد بات بالفشل
وجاء في البيان ايضا ان الجيش يعتمد
استراتيجيه قتاليه لتقليل الخسائر بين
المدنيه
هذا وطالب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات نقلتها
وكاله رويترز عن حسابه في تويتر طلب
المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد
ما اسماها بجرائم رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
الصوت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
وقبل ذلك نفى مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للعربيه ما تم نشره من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع حول اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد
المصدر للعربيه ان الاشتباكات جرت حول
مقري البرهان واحمدتي وتم ابعاد هذه
القوات وان فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع
لمقر البرهان مضلل وغير حقيقي
الله اكبر
لمزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى الخرطوم ينضم
الي من هناك مراسل العربيه سلم الهاشمي
سالم اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني
في هذه الاوقات واين تتركز الاشتباكات يا
سالم
سالم هل تسمعني
يبدو ان السالم لا يسمعني حتى الساعه لنا
عوده اليه في سياق هذه التغطيه بطبيعه
الحال على كل خريطه المعارك اعزائي
المشاهدين على الارض تنتشر في العديد من
النقاط الساخنه سواء في العاصمه الخرطوم
او في خارجها وتدور اكثر المعارك شراسه في
مناطق متعدده من العاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها
مقر القياده العامه للجيش الواقع في شمال
العاصمه فالاقتتال كما ذكرنا مستمر في
محيط مقر القياده وسط انباء متضاربه حول
الجهه المسيطره على هذا المبدا مبنى اخر
في العاصمه الخرطوم كان مسرحا للاقتتال
بين الطرفين وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي
يتواجد في المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه
وكانت قوات الدعم السريع قد اعلنت سيطرتها
قبل ذلك قبل ان يمشي الجيش هذا البيان
لاحقا اما في ام درمان فقد دارت اشتباكات
في محيط مبنى التلفزيون بعد محاوله قوات
الدعم السريع السيطره عليه وفقا للجيش
الذي عاد واعنن سيطرته على المبنى بشكل
كامل
وبعيدا عن العاصمه الخرطوم هذه المره في
شمال البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه مروي التي
شهدت اندلاع الشراره الاولى للمواجهه
فان مصير مطار مروي الذي يقع في الجزء
الشرقي من المدينه ما يزال معلقا في ظل
اعلان كل طرف عن بسط السيطره عليه
اعود الى مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي من
الخرطوم سالم اذا كنت تسمعني جديد المشهد
الميداني في هذه الاوقات واين تتركز
الاشتباكات يا سالم
نعم اهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين
الاشتباكات الان تتجدد في مناطق مختلفه من
العاصمه الخرطوم لكن ابرزها في منطقه
محيط القياده العامه للجيش وكذلك هنا في
منطقه بحري في كوبر كذلك هذه
ابرز الاماكن التي يسمع فيها ذوي لاطلاق
الرصاصات والادويه الانفجارات
المتكرره كذلك الان صدر ايضا
بيان من الجيش وفيديو كذلك ان قوات الدعم
السريع
تقول القوات المسلحه انها ستنشر يعني
فيديو لان القوه القوات الدعم السريع غير
متواجده في القياده العامه ولم تسيطر
عليها في المقابل هناك ايضا فيديو مصور
للقوات الدعم السريع تنفي فيه ايضا سيطره
الجيش على مقر الاذاعه والتلف زيون كذلك
ايضا
[موسيقى]
اللينه تطباء السودان وكذلك
اللجنه الاطباء السودان ولجنه نقابه اطباء
السودان كذلك كلهم الان بداوا في مناشدات
للمساعدات
ويناسبون بفتح الممرات الامنه في هذه
اللحظات في من اجل السلامه المواطنين اولا
ومن اجل ايضا تقديم العون والمساعده
للمصابين والجرحى في المستشفيات المختلفه
ونحن نقول هذا الكلام
او
بهذا الامر يعني نذكر بانه هناك قلائف
وقعت على مستشفى ابن سينا وهو احد
المستشفيات المهمه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وادى لضرر في بعض مبانيه وسقوط قنائس
عشوائيه عليه جراء الاشتباكات المستمره
حتى الان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ايضا بخلاف الاضرار التي تقع على بقيه
المشافي والمستشفيات يجد الاطباء والمرضى
صعوبات كبيره في الوصول مستشفيات القريبه
من اماكن الاشتباك التي تؤدي اليها ايضا
لجنه اطباء السودان كانت قد ذكرت بان
مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي اصبح خارج
الخدمه الان
ومستشفى مستشفى الشعب هو في ليس بعيد من
المقر القياده العامه للجيش ومكان
الاشتباكات الان الان وانا اتحدث اليك
ايضا استمع الى صوت مروحيه تحلق في في
سماء الخرطوم سالم نوعيه الاسلحه
المستخدمه هذا اليوم من قبل الطرفين هل من
اعطائنا فقط يعني لمحه عن هذه الاسلحه
نعمل الاسلحه في الاغلب التي تستخدم منذ
بدا هذه الاشتباكات تستخدم اسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه
من الاسلحه التي تستخدم بكل تاكيد
الكلاشنكوف وغيرها من
البندقيات
المستخدمه كل انواع البندقيات يمكن ان
نقول وايضا استخدام السلاح الثقيل بدا من
الدوشكا التي تستخدم وهي استخدمت كثيرا في
هذه الاشتباكات الدوشكا التي هي تاتي في
في سيارات الدفع الرباعي ويتم استخدامها
من قبل قوات الدعم السريع كذلك تم استخدام
ايضا مضاد الطيران الرباعي والثنائي وهي
المضادات تاتي ايضا في
سيارات الدفع الرباعي كذلك تستخدمت هذه
المضادات استخدمت ايضا الجرن اوف الار بي
جي ايضا تم استخدامها انواع المقذوفات
كذلك هذه المقذوفات ايضا استخد بشكل كبير
وتم تبادل بها
اطلاق النار بشكل كبير هناك اصوات كبيره
وفي في هذه المقذوفات هناك نوع من
المقذوفات يتم استخدامه يسمع دويه بقوه
اما استخدامه بشكل كبير كذلك في هذه
الاشتباكات طيب سالم ابقى معي سعود اليك
بعد قليل فقط
لنعطي هذه الاطلاله على الاوضاع الطبيه في
السودان نتيجه هذه المواجهات فقد دائنت
لقبه اطباء السودان الصراع على السلطه بين
طرفين نزاع مع خروج مستشفيات عده عن
الخدمه تماما ابرزها مستشفى الشعب
التعليمي والخرطوم التعليمي كما ذكر
مراسلنا منذ قليل وقالت النقابه ان قصف
المرافق الصحيه يعد انتهاكا واضحا للقانون
الدولي الانساني والمواثيق ذات الصله
وقبل ذلك تعرض مستشفى ابن سينا وهو احد
اكبر المستشفيات في العاصمه الخرطوم تعرض
الى اضرار بالغه في بعض مبني بعد سقوط
قذائف عشوائيه عليه جراء الاشتباكات
المستمره والعنيفه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم
وبخلاف الاضرار التي تقع على المستشفيات
يجدوا الاطباء والمرضى صعوبات كبيره في
الوصول الى المستشفيات القريبه من اماكن
الاشتباكات
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان
ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا الاشتباكات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الى سبعه وتسعين
قتيلا ووفق البيان فان عدد القتل يتجاوز
هذه الحصيله لاسيما وان الكثيرين منهم لم
ينقلوا الى المستشفيات اما بسبب الوضع
الحرج او لصعوبه في التنقل
[موسيقى]
اعود الى مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي من
الخرطوم الذي يتابع هذه المواجهات وتطورات
الاوضاع عن كثب سالم يعني لليوم الثالث
على التوالي وهنالك تضارب كبير في الانباء
حول حدود سيطره كل طرف على هذه المواقع
الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم لماذا هذا
التضارب يستمر بهذا الشكل وهل يستطيع اي
طرف ثالث تاكيد او نفي سيطره هذا الطرف او
ذاك على هذه المواقع هل هنالك اي طرف
محايد ان صح التعبير يستطيع تاكيد سيطره
هذا الطرف او نفي سيطره ذاك الطرف على هذا
الموقع
نعم يعني هذا الموضوع ظل محل شد وجذب منذ
انطلاق هذه الازمه او هذه الحرب لكن ايضا
ننوه الى ان وزاره الخارجيه كانت قصدها
اصدرت بيانا وقالت فيه ان البرهان اصدر
قرارا بحل الدعم السريع واعلانه قوه
متمرده
الان هنا ايضا صوت مدافع ليست بعيده من
المكان الذي اقف فيه هنا في تحديد
[موسيقى]
حقيقه لكن احيانا يتم تاكيد هذه المعاني
بانه الدعم السريع او الجيش السوداني تقوم
بنشر فيديوهات لهذا الموقع ويتم بعد ذلك
طلب ذلك يؤكدون ان هذه الصور حقيقيه وهي
فعلا من هذا الموقع ويتم تاكيد هذا المعنى
طيب هل هنالك اي حديث الان عن وقف جديد
لاطلاق النار سالم بعدها
فشل يعني موضوع وقف اطلاق النار السابق
الذي تم برعايه من الامم المتحده بالامس
هل هنالك حديث الان عن اي احتماليه لوقف
اطلاق نار ولو لساعه
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي حديث عن وقف
لاطلاق النار او حتى الهدنه التي كانت
بالامس هدنه الامس التي راى كثيرون انها
لم
يعني لم يتم الاستفاده منها يعني لم
يستفيد منها المواطن ولم تستفيد منها
القوتين المتقاتلتين اصلا حتى يعني هذه
الهدنه اعلنت وبعد اعلانها مباشره
انطلقت الاشتباك مره اخرى طيب سالم
بالنسبه الى الموضوع المعيشي الحياتي يعني
كيف يصرف الناس او يتمكن الناس السودانيون
في الخرطوم تصريف امور امورهم الحياتيه
اليوميه في ظل هذه الاشتباكات والمواجهات
سواء في موضوع الماكل المشرب هل المدارس
جميعها مقفله حركه التنقل لو تعطينا فكره
سالم
نعم بالنسبه لحركه التنقل الان حركه
التنقل صعبه جدا لا يمكن التنقل في ظل هذه
الاجواء
الاجواء التي يسمع فيها دوي الرصاص وكذلك
تبادل اطلاق النار بالمدافع كذلك لا يمكن
الان وانا اتحدث معك هناك اصوات لتبادل
اطلاق نار ومروحيه هنا في بحري وفي هذه
المنطقه التي اتواجد فيها بالنسبه للحياه
المعيشيه طبعا صعبه فعلا الوضع الانساني
بشكل عام يعاني فيه المواطن السوداني بكل
تاكيد من توفر المواد الغذائيه الان اعاده
الطوابير وصفوف الخبز امام المخابز
العديد من الاشكاليات في توفير المواد
الغذائيه نفسها البقالات واماكن تقديم هذه
الخدمه ايضا
يعانون من الامداد نفسه امداد الدقيق
امداد المواد الغذائيه بحكم ان الحركه
مغلقه بالكامل نعم من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي دائما شكرا جزيلا لك
سلم على كل هذه المتابعه اعزائي المشاهدين
ومع احتدام المعارك تبرز سيناريوهات
الموقف الراهن في السودان على هذه الحال
رغم الضبابيه الصوره فان سيناريو الحرب
الاهليه ما يزال مستبعدا حتى الساعه
فالجيش حث المدنيين على عدم الانقراض في
المعارك الجاريه والسبب انها معركه على
السلطه في المقام الاول بحسب مراقبين اما
سيناريو وعدم الحسم فانه وارد ايضا مع
تصعيد الدعم السريع هجومه ليلا بالمدفعيه
لكن ميزان القوه للجيش سيمكنه في النهايه
من الحسم ان لم يتطور الموقف الى حرب
شوارع في العاصمه
السيناريو الثالث يرجح ان امد الحرب لن
يطول كثيرا اي انها معركه محدوده زمنيه
ويدعم هذا المؤشر الانشقاقات من جانب
المنتدبين في الدعم السريع بالاضافه
الى الانشقاقات القياديه اما السيناريو
الرابع فهو الرهان على الوساطه الخارجيه
وهو القاسم المشترك بين الطرفين لكنه هجوم
الدعم السريع ليلا يشي بانهم يحاولون
الحسم قبل بدء الوساطات في حين يؤكد الجيش
انه لن يرضى بالوساطه قبل ردع الدعم
السريع
وننتهي مع السيناريو الاخير الذي يرجح ان
تعود قوات الدعم السريع الى دارفور مجددا
والتحرك من هناك كقوه الانفصاليه يصعب نزع
شوكتها
عسكر للسكنات
ولاحظات حره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذهب الى القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل ينضم الي من هناك البحث في
العلاقات الدوليه احمد سيد احمد سيد احمد
اهلا وسهلا بك اولا اريد قراءه منك
لمجريات القتال في يومه الثالث في السودان
واي سيناريو سواء سياسي او عسكري سيتمظهر
برايك نتيجه هذه المواجهات في الايام
المقبله وهل سنكون امام حرب مفتوحه ام لا
هذا
تحياتي لك ولكل مشاهدي قناه العربيه
الكرام في الواقع الان الحرب هي حرب مقرات
بالاساس هو اربع او خمس مقرات هي كل طرف
يعتبر ان السيطره عليها قد حسم المعركه
وربما هذا مقاربه خاطئه من كلا الطرفين
يعني سواء المقر القياده العامه او مقر
التليفزيون او مقر القصر الجمهوري او
غيرها من المقرات الحيويه اختزلت المعركه
فيها حتى الان وهذه خلال الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه هناك حاله من القر والفار في ظل
غياب طرف ثالث كما اشرت من قبل يؤكد صحه
ماذا سيطر كل طرف وما هو قوه كل طرف من
الواضح ان المعارك تتم بطريقه عشوائيه ان
الاسلوب الدعم الشعبي القائم على العربات
الدفع الرباعي سريعه التحرك يقوم بهجمات
خاطفه يسيطر بعض الاشياء ويكون ما ينسحب
عندما يكون هناك هجوم مضاد ثم يعود القاره
مره اخرى في ظل صعوبه ربما التحرك الاسلحه
التي يم الجيش وهي الدبابات والاسلحه
الثقيله وبالتالي في ظل وجود غياب طرف
يؤكد صحه هذه البيانات الان هناك حرب
مقرات بيتزامن معها حرب اعلاميه ان كل طرف
بدا يستخدم الاعلام والفيديوهات كاحد
الوسائل للرفع الروح المعنويه من ناحيه
ولاظهار انه قادر على حسم المعركه من
الناحيه الاخرى ثم لنفي ما يقوم الطرف
الاخر بنسبه اليه من سيطره على احد هذه
المقرات لكن انا في اعتقادي ان المؤشرات
الايام الثلاثه وهذا القتال وبيشير الى ان
السيناريو الاقرب هو ان تظل المعارك
بعض الوقت لكن الناس تظل محدوده بمعنى
انها ستظل ربما بشكل كبير داخل الخرطومه
العاصمه من ناحيه الامر الثاني ان اطراف
ايضا المعارك ستظل فقط داخل الاطراف
العسكريه سواء قوات الدعم من ناحيه او
قوات الجيش السوداني من ناحيه اخرى ولن
تنتقل الى ربما يعني
طبقات او فئات او شرائح جديده يعني تنتقل
للانصار هذا وانصار هذا في الاحياء والمدن
لكن على الاقل هي هي بين الطرفين ثم ايضا
من النحاس الثالثه ان كل طرف هناك نوع من
التوازن القوى الذي حتى يضعف او يصاحب من
سيطره الطرف على كامل الامور
يعني حاله الحسم لليوم الثالث على التاويل
تحديدا
امام هذه المقرات الاستراتيجيه في العاصمه
الخرطوم تدل على ماذا وفي حال استمر
القتال على هذه الشاكله هل نحن نقترب من
حرب مفتوحه ولكن بخطوط تماس معروفه لكل
طرف وهذا استاتيكو سيظل قائم في الايام
والاشهر المقبله ام لا نحن نتجه الى حرب
اوسع وربما حرب مفتوحه
انا في اعتقادي اذا لم يتم حذف حسم حرب
المقرات خلال الايام القليله القادمه
ستنتقل المعارك الى جبهات اوسع واكبر لان
الحالات النحاس هي سببها كما اشرنا هي
غياب او ربما وجود عدم استراتيجيه
الدفاعيه او هجوميه من جانب طرف الاخر
المعارك تقوم على القر والفر على معارك
العشوائيه تقوم على ان هناك هجمات مبرته
لكن على الاقل استمرار المعارك ويزيد من
التكلفه لكل طرف ان هناك الاسلحه هناك
التموين هناك الامداد وبالتالي هذا ربما
حتى يكون عامل في اجبار الطرفين على الاقل
في هذه المرحله الى بسط السيطره على
المقارات او التركيز عليها فقط انتظارا
لاعلان انه منتصر او او الطرف الاخر
وانتظارا ايضا التحركات والوسطات الان لان
في اعتقادي بعد ثلاثه ايام كان كل طرف
يقول انه خلال ساعات وفي الصباح الباكر
ثاني يوم سيحسم الارض لكن بعد ثلاثه ايام
ومع الصعوبه ومع هل هذا التنقل ربما بدا
كلهم يتراجع خطوه الى الوراء وربما يفسح
المجال كما دعا حماتي اليوم الى تدخل
الدولي هذا بيعني ان هناك بدات القناعه
لدى الجانبين في ان صعوبه او استحاله على
الاقل هذا الحسم العسكري في خلال ايام
المقبله استاذ احمد ارجو ان تبقى معي انضم
الي الان البحث في شؤون الدفاع الدكتور
رياض قهوه الدكتور اهلا وسهلا بك ساكون
معك بعد قليل ولكن اعزائي المشاهدين مع
التحليق المكثف للطائرات الحربيه للجيش
اليوم الثالث يبدو ان السيطره على القواعد
العسكريه الجويه الشغله الشاغل الان لدى
قوات الدعم السريعه فسلاح الجو وفق
عسكريين هو النقطه الفاصله في المعركه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فمن يحكم
السيطره او فمن يحكم السيطره عليه يحسم
المعركه نتابع
في السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه
قوات الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه
تعلم ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه
فكانت البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حميدتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مروي الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده مروي لاحتوائها على
اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم مركز
فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار وتليها
اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخاب ئ
الطائرات وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء
السالم العربيه
ونستكمل اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه من
قناه العربيه لتطورات الاوضاع على
الدراماتيكيه في السودان انضم الي الان في
الاستوديو البحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع
الزميل الدكتور القهوجي دكتور اهلا وسهلا
بك اريد قراءتك اولا لمجريات اليوم الثالث
من هذه المعارك اولا هل تفاجات
بتطور الاوضاع بهذا الشكل على الارض في
السودان ثم زوبعه المواقف المتناقضه حول
حدود سيطره كل طرف على المقرات
الاستراتيجيه يعني كل ساعه بقول طرف انا
سيطرت على هذا المبنى بيرجع على هداك
الطرف بيمفي وكل واحد بينشر فيديو طيب هل
في مثل هكذا حالات ومواجهات هل هذا يعني
مساله طبيعيه ام لا ولماذا لم يستطع اي
طرف حتى الساعه الحسم في هذه المقرات
انا تفاجات
لم اكن اتوقع ان ينفجر الوضع بهذا الشكل
توقعنا يكون هناك بعض المناوشات انما
ينفجر بشكل حرب شامله بين الطرفين
طبعا تفاجات
لا نزال نجهل العديد من النقاط اولا ما هو
الحجم الفعلي فقوه بشريه للطرفين
ما هو حجم احتياط الذخائر السلاح لكل من
الطرفين حكي عن العديد من الشقاقات مدى
صحتها هذه امور تتبلور خلال الايام
المقبره تصبح اكثر وضوحا
هل هناك امدادات ذخيره لهذه الاطراف طريقه
انتشارها
وبالتالي ما نشهده اليوم هو محاوله سيطر
على مواقف
لتحسين الموقف الاستراتيجي ميدانيا الجيش
يحاول الاستعاده السيطره على نقاط
استراتيجيه ومحوريه
للطرف الاخر قوه الدعم السريع ميزه حرب
العصابات هذه نتذكر انها كانت ميليشيات
متمرسه في حرب عصابات وبالتالي هي تقاتل
اليوم في اسلوب حرب العصابات حرب العصابات
عليك ان تدخل تسيطر على مبنى في شارع
وتعلن انك احدثت انتصار الجيش يتحدث
بطريقه مختلفه الجيش يسيطر على محاور ومن
ثم يعدد انا سيطرت على هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي مقاييس كل طرف للسيطره تختلف عن
الاخر بالاخير انه مفهوم حرب عصابات يواجه
مفهوم قوات مسلحه نظاميه انما
تجري في وقت
تشهد يعني تطورات سريعه هناك استخدام
للسلاح الثقيل
السيطره الجويه هي اساس من سيمترك السيطره
على
السماء سيسيطر على العديد من المواقع
الارض انما
هنتحدث هنا عن طائرات بذخائر ذكيه تستطيع
ان تحقق اصابات دقيقه للاسف القوات مسلحه
السودانيه حتى الان تسليحها تسليح يعود
الاتحاد السوفيتي تستيح صيني حجم ما يعرف
بالاسلحه الدقيقه الذكيه جدا قليل قوات
المسلحه وبالتالي لقوات الجويه تاثير انما
ليس بتاثير للنراه عند امتلاك اسلحه دقيقه
دكتور كان البعض يتوقع حرب سريعا انه
خاطفه يستطيع الجيش حسب المعركه عم نشوف
الامور ضبابيه في حال كانت سلاسل الامداد
بالذخائر للطرفين
متوفره هل نتوقع حربا مفتوحه قد تطول
وتطول لاشهر وربما سنوات ام لا
اذا كان هناك دعم شعبي
متوازن او متساوي للطرفين
او نقول ان كان هناك دعم شعبي بنسبه قويه
او جيده
لقوات الدعم السريع
ستكون هناك حرب اهليه للاسف ستطول الحرب
ستكون هناك بيئه حاضنه وحاميه لها سيمكنها
من العمل العسكري باسلوب حرب عصابات ضد
الجيش النظامي لفتره طويله وهذا سيطير من
امد الازمه ونضف عليها ان كان هناك دعم
دولي او جهه خارجيه تدعم وتسلح هذه القوه
هذا سيطيل من امد الازمه انما ان كان هناك
نسبه كبرى من الدعم الشعبي المؤيد لطرف
اذا قوات المسلحه مع دعم دوله كبير لهذه
الجهه اعتقد ان لن تتحول الى حرب اهليه
سنشهد يعني عمليه حسم قد تطول انما قد
تؤدي بالنهايه الى ابقاء السودان كدوله
موحده ولا تشد يعني للاسف انقسمات او حرب
اهليه طيب دعني اسرق السيد احمد مجددا من
القاهره استاذ احمد لماذا تبدو الخرطوم
كانها ام المعارك يعني وهل السيطره على
هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم يعني
انه ربح طرف على الطرف الاخر بالضربه
القاضيه ام لا يعني ممكن يعني انه يسيطر
طرف على هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه في
الخرطوم والطرف اخر يسيطر على مواقع
استراتيجيه في ولايات ومدن اخرى ما رايك
يعني بالفعل الخرطوم هي تمثل الراس تمثل
الرمز وتمثل الحكم الثلاثه معا وبالتالي
من يسيطر على هذه الامور يستطيع ان يسيطر
على كل السودان يعني من الصعب عمليا بحجم
القوات او الانتشار ان يكون ان تمتد
المعارك لكل انحاء السوداني لكل الولايات
نتكلم عن السودان هو قاره ليس منطقه صغيره
او مدينه وانما هي ولايات متعدده متراميه
الاطراف وبالتالي الانتقال والاعتاد
العسكري سيكون مكلف وبايظ وليس في امكان
كلا الطرفين ومن ثم المعركه الان هي حتى
تختزل فقط ليس في كل الخرطوم ولكن في رموز
الدوله السودانيه المقر القياده العامه
القصر الجمهوري التلفزيون الذي يعني سوف
يسيطر على التلفزيون والقذف ويعلن السيطره
هو يعتقد ان هذا يكون له الحكم وبالتالي
يحسم الامور الامر الثاني ان الحاله عدم
الثقه بين الجانبين منعدمه تماما يعني
واضح ان انهم وصل الى طريق اللاعوده
وبالتالي كل طرف يس استهداف راس الطرف
الاخر يعني يحاول ان يفصل ما بين الراس
والجسد الدعم الشعبي يقول انه ليس في
معركه مع الجيش انه يريد محاكمه بعض
قياداته عملا الانشقاق في المقابل الجيش
يقول ان ليس معركه مع المئه الف مقاتل بل
دعا لدمجهم
ولكن هي المعركه مع قريه تمرد الذين
يقودون وبالتالي هنا المعركه من مصلحه
الطرفين التضييقها وليس التوسيعها
وبالتالي هنا التظل الخرطوم هي الرمز من
يسيطر على المقرات وسيطر على الخرطوم
اعتقد سيحسم له الامر الغالب ربما نشهد
بعض التحركات الاخرى هنا ستكون المعارك
اسهل لانها مترميه الاطراف السلاح الجوي
ربما يكون اكثر فاعليه على عكس معركه
الخرطوم ان وسط مناطق سكنيه الدقه
والاستهداف لا يمكن ان تكون بفاعليه مع
الطائرات مع عربيات دفع رباعي تتحرك في
الشوارع وبالتالي هنا معركه الخرطوم هي
المعركه الحاسمه ما بين الجانبين على
الاقل في خلال الايام احمد في مساله اخرى
يجب الاضاءه عليها البعد القبلي والعشائري
والجهوي يجب اخذه بعين الاعتبار في بلد
مثل السودان الى اي مدى استمرار المواجهات
بهذا الشكل
ينذر بصراع قبلي وعشائري على امتداد كامل
السودان
يعني نميز هنا بين الصراعه القابله من
منظرين صراع سياسي ام صراع عسكري يعني حتى
الان هناك السودان بطبيعته والشعب
السوداني هو شعب مسلم كما يقولون لديه
فائض سياسه يعني يتظاهر منذ 2019 ولديه
اصرار على الديمقراطيه والانتخابات
وبالتالي ليس لديه نزعه العسكريه او نظريه
المباراه الصفريه في القضاء الامر الثاني
ايضا مفهوم العسكره يعني الاسلحه حتى الان
هي مركزه فقط بيد القوات النظاميه القوات
المسلحه وفي المقابل قوات الدفع السريع
هنا الخطوره لو انتقلت هذه
الاسلحه او اسلحه مختلفه الى حضانات شعبيه
لكل طرف وقبائل هنا نشهد السيناريو الاسوا
حقيقه وهو الحرب الاهليه الشامله حرب
الشوارع لكن على الاقل انا في اعتقادي ان
هناك شبه ربما توافق او غالبيه ميلاد
الشعب السوداني حتى من انصار كلا الطرفين
برفض هذه المواجهه هذا الحرب باعتبار انه
نسف للدم السوداني ليس احتقان يدعو الى
الاحتقان هذا الدم ان المعركه هي معركه
بين اشخاص وليس معركه معركه وطنيه معركه
للدفاع عن السودان وبالتالي هذا الصراع هو
لم يكسب حتى كل طرف
ان يدفع اطرافه الاستاذ احمد استاذ احمد
ارجو ان تبقى ارجو ان تبقى معي اعزائي
المشاهدين هذه صور تردنا الان
لسيطره القوات الجيش السوداني على معسكر
لقوات الدعم السريع في الفاشر كما يقال لي
اذا صور لسيطره وحدات من الجيش السوداني
برئاسه الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان على
معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع في الفاشر
بالطبع نحن لا نستطيع تاكيد هذه
الفيديوهات من مصادر مستقله ولكن هذه
تريدنا في كل مره يعني يخرج كل طرف
وينشر هذه الفيديوهات ثم ياتي طرف اخر
وينفي ما يتم تداوله ولكن نعرضها عليكم
كما ترد الينا اذا السوداني ينشر فيديو
لسيطره قواته على معسكر لقوات الدعم
السريه في
الفاشر دكتور رياض هل زج الجيش السوداني
برايك بكافه وكامل عتاده واسلحته في هذه
المعركه ام لا هو يبقي اسلحه لمرحله اخرى
برايك هو لا يستطيع استخدام كل شيء هناك
حرب مدن لا يمكن استخدام العديد من
الاسلحه في داخل الحرب المدن
يمكن استخدامها في مناطق المفتوحه يستخدم
دبابات مدرعات مدفعيه ثقيله طائرات انما
لا يستطيع ان يستخدم
كافه انواع هذه الاسلحه في كافه انواع
المواجهات التي يخوضها هي لن تنفعه في
عمليه اقتحام مباني وشوارع ضيقه وازقه
يحتاج الى القوات الخاصه الى
قوات المشاه
انما
القوه النيران تعطيه
الافضليه في المواجهات المفتوحه السيطره
على معسكرات قواعد عسكريه الى اخره
المنشات كبيره هنا تظهر
اهميه كثافه النيران ونوعيه السلاح
المستخدم انما في سيناريوات حرب الشوارع
والسيطره على شوارع هذا قتال تقوم به قوات
خاصه والمشاهد دكتور
هو يحاول سيطر على مناطق استراتيجيه
بالنسبه لها يعني معايير
اهدافه الاساسيه لماذا انطلق التوقيت الى
اخره طبعا اراد ان يحتفظ بعنصر المفاجاه
يستفيد من عنصر المفاجئ ان يكون هو
المبادر في العمل لانه يدرك ان هناك فارق
في ميزان القوات لصالح الجيش وبالتالي ان
قام هو في المبادره وبسيطر على اماكن
استراتيجيه
سيكون له
هامش تقدم
باتجاه الجهه الاخرى وهو يعوض اليوم اعتقد
انه يعول اليوم على تدخلات من قبائل
داخليه ومن الخارج تؤدي لوقف نار
تبقيه على مكتسباته
يعني اعتقد ان هذا اتجاه استراتيجيه
الدعم السريع
هل ستنجح هل سيستطيع الجيش باستعاده هذه
القواعد
وتعويض الخسائر في بشكل سريع
هذا ما نشاهده اليوم يعني اعتقد ان هناك
حاليا معركه كسر عظم يعني
يريد استعاده المبادره بشكل سريع طبعا طيب
دكتور ابقى معي سيد احمد ابقى معي سنواصل
هذه التغطيه بعد قليل اعزائي المشاهدين
نفى مصدر في الجيش السوداني للعربيه ما تم
نشره من قبل قوات الدعم السريع حول اقتحام
مقر اقامه البرهان واكد المصدر العربي ان
الاشتباكات جرت حول مقري البرهان واحمدتي
وتم ابعادهما
وان فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر
البرهان مضلل وغير حقيقي
قبل ذلك طالب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات النقلتها
وكاله على حسابه في تويتر طالب المجتمع
الدولي
بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد ما اسماها
بجرائم رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان
انضم اليه الان من الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه
عبد الله عطيه وهو سكرتير عامل لجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان المنتخبه
الدكتور عطيه اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه لو
تعطينا فكره عن اخر الارقام المتوفره
لديكم لعدد ضحايا هذه المواجهات سواء من
قتلى او من جرحى اخر تحديث لديكم
نعم شكرا جزيلا للتحديث هو اكثر من 100
شهيد حتى اللحظه وسط المدنيين من الخرطوم
وخارج الخرطوم
الاكثر خطوره هي ما تحدثنا عنه عن تكدس
جثث في الشوارع لم نصل اليها ولم تتوارث
الينا معلومات اكثر عنها لذلك نحن طالبنا
منذ صبيحه اليوم بفتحه او من الامس عفوا
بفتح الممرات امنه ووقف اطلاق فوري للنار
كذلك تم استهداف عدد من المستشفيات
بالاسلحه الثقيله وهما يهدد استمرار
العمليات الانسانيه والطبيه داخل هذه
المنشات كذلك ايضا سقطت شهيده طبيبه صبيحه
هذا اليوم ليكتمل العدد الى اربعه شهداء
وسط الاطباء نسال الله يتقبلهم جميعا نبي
واسع رحمته وكذلك كل الشهداء السودانيين
الوضع الصحي ينبي
بخطوره وخطوره كبيره جدا ارسلنا نداء عاجل
الى مجلس المنعقد خلال هذا اليوم عبر
نقابه اطباء السودان ونقابات الاطباء
السودانيين في سته دول حول العالم
مناشدتنا للامم المتحده بالضغط على طرفي
القتال بالوقت الفوري اللي هذه الحرب
العبثيه وكذلك نطالب ايضا
باجلاء هؤلاء الجثث وفتح الممرات للوصول
الى هذه هل هل كل هؤلاء هل كل هؤلاء
الضحايا هم من المدنيين يعني قلت اكثر من
قتيل هل هم من المدنيين ام لا بينهم
عسكريون دكتور عطيه
هل هنالك الاعداد كبيره جدا اخرى نحن
نتحدث عن
العسكريين اغلبهم موجودين في مستشفيات
عسكريه لم يتم حصره حتى الان الذي يجب
الذي يجب معرفته ان هذه الارقام بسيطه جدا
لانه الوصول الى هذه المستشفيات صعب جدا
يعني بالامس تحدثت
وسائل الاعلام ان هنالك امراه ذهبت
للموضوع في المستشفى ولكن استهدفت هي
ووالدها عليهم رحمه الله هذا الوضع يعني
الوصول الى المستشفيات في خطوره كبيره
دكتور عطيه هل هنالك عدد من المستشفيات
خرجت عن الخدمه وابرز احتياجاتكم لو تقل
لنا ما هي ابرز احتياجاتكم عبر قناه
العربيه كاطباء
مستعدين ان يدفعوا من حر مالهم لتسيير هذه
المستشفيات ولكن للاسف حتى محطات الوقود
مغلقه لذلك نحن نداءنا
الدولي
ه الا تساعدكم الا تتلقون اي مساعده من
المنظمات الاماميه العامله في السودان
دكتور عطيه نعم
[موسيقى]
نطالب بهذه الممرات العامله ليس لنا فقط
ايضا هي نطالب بحمايه اصدقائنا وحلفائنا
من المنظمات الدوليه التي تحاول ان تساعد
الشعب السوداني دكتور عطيه شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه
المشاركه من الخرطوم اعزائي المشاهدين
شكلت الازمه الراهنه في السودان ضربه
جديده الاقتصاد البلاد واستمرار الصراع
العسكري قد يجعل من الصعب خروج البلاد من
الازمه الاقتصاديه الضاريه بجود الضاربه
بجذورها لعقود النظر
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت امال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
المساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري
دولار سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت
تعليق مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان في اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نمو طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من
154% وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم السنوي
نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل الازمه
الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه معظم
احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل تدهور
قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا سجل
السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجل في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه واستراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
واعود الى ضيوف في هذه التغطيه سيد احمد
من القاهره هل ما يجري في السودان هو شان
داخلي سوداني بحد بمعنى صراع على السلطه
بين طرفين ام لا يعني هذا تسطيح
لما يجري ما يجري هو انعكاس لصراع اقليمي
ودولي اكبر
على المشهد السياسي في السودان ما رايك
بالفعل اتفق معك فانه اسراء اعمق واكبر
وليس صراعا داخليا سودانيا فقط ولكن ذو
ابعاد اقليميه وابعاد دوليه لان دائما
ساحات الحروب الاهليه او الحروب الممتده
كما نرى في الكثير من دول العالم دائما ما
تدخل على الخط اطراف دوليه واطراف اقليميه
للاستفاده والتوظيف هذه الصراعات في تمرير
اجندات اجنداتها من ناحيه وتصفيه حساباتها
مع القوه الاخرى الملوئه لها مع سواء في
النظام الدولي او النظام الاقليمي وهذا
بطبعي يعقد من الازمه لان الواضح الان ان
هنا الفجوه تتسع ما بين طرفي الصراع وما
بين الشعب السوداني حتى الان الذي ربما لم
يثق من هذه الصدمه الذي كان يرى ان الصراع
والصراع السياسي فقط وهناك ازمه اقتصاديات
طاحنه ثم تضاف لها ازمه عسكريه وازمه
امنيه ستفاقب من الازمتين السياسيه
وبالتالي مستقبل الاطار هو يعني اصبح الان
الى غير اجل غير مسمى ثم الاخطر كما اشارت
تقرير هو الازمه الاقتصاديه كل هذه البيئه
تضعف من المناعه الداخليه للسودان
وبالتالي تدفع الاطراف الخارجيه والدوليه
الى التدخل والى محاوله التاثير في
مباريات الامور لتوزيع نحو مسار معين قد
يتعارض بالضروره مع مصالح الشعب السوداني
او قد يدفع الى الاستقرار وهذا الصراع
الابعد والاعمق هو الذي سيحكم مسار ونهايه
وطبيعه هذا الصراع هل سينتهي في القريب
العاجل ام ستظل حروب مفتوحه مع امدادات
عسكريه ربما مع مواقف سياسيه معينه لان
المجتمع الدولي دائما في كل الازمات بما
فيها الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه كان دائما
جزء من المشكله وليس من الحل لان هناك
تضارب مصالح تضارب اجندات وبالتالي هنا
الصداع السودان الذي يعاني منذ سنوات من
يعني مناعه ضعيفه هشه اعتقد ان الادوار
الخارجيه ستكون يعني اكثر
تاثيرا في الفتره المقبله وايضا فيما
يتعلق بخيارات وقرارات وتوجهات الطرفيه
الصراع اذا كان يقبل الوساطه ام سيستمر في
الرهان العسكري كل هذا سيحكمه هو سيحدده
الاطراف والدوليه دكتور رياض في حال ظل
هذا الستاتيكو على ما هو عليه نقول لمده
اسبوع اسبوعين سنه
هل يعني السيناريو الليبي يكون اقرب الى
التمظهر في المشهد السوداني بمعنى انه كل
طرف اخذ مناطقه في خطوط تماس وكل طرف له
دعم اقليمي وخارجي وبتضل الامور الى ما لا
نهايه هل هذا السيناريو برايك واقعي ام لا
تستبعده سيناريو حتى الان وارد طالما لم
يتمكن
الجيش النظامي من السيطره على كافه
المواقع وبقي هناك طرف اخر يسيطر على
ولايات ومواقع استراتيجيه طبعا سنتجه
لسيناريو شبيه بالسيناريو الليبي للاسف
خاصه ان وجد كل من الطرفين راعي دولته
كان هناك رعاه دوليين لكلا الطرفين سنشهد
سيناريو شبيه جدا بالسيناريو الليبي للاسف
يعني هذا اعتقد ان هذا ما يحاول البرهان
اليوم تجنبه
يعني اقدام الجيش على هذا العمل العسكري
الواسع اليوم هو يهدف
للحفاظ على وحده الاراضي منع
يمنع
وقوات الدعم السريع من اثبات وجودها
والاستمرار بوجودها كقوه فاعله على الارض
في جميع الولايات
لا خيار اخر يعني حتى لا اعتقد ان فكره
وقف اطلاق نار ستكون وارده ان لم يكن هناك
معها
تسليم من طرف لاخر
لان وقف اطلاق نار
بحفاظ على كل طرف مكتسباته يعني نحن
توجهنا الى السيناريو الليبي طيب
استاذ احمد
في حال استمرت هذه المواجهات بهذا الشكل
هل هذا يفتح الباب واسعا امام تدخل دوري
اكبر في المشهد السوداني مع ما يعنيها
التدخل الدولي
وكلنا نعرف ماذا يعني هذا هذا الكلام ما
بالطبع يعني استمرار الصراع واستمرار حاله
اللحسم السياسي والعسكري في هذه المعارك
هو بيفتح الباب على مصرعيه بالطبع
للتدخلات الخارجيه وهذا بدوره سيعقد من
الازمه ويطيل امادها وندخل في سيناريوهات
رايناها في مناطق اخرى او في دول اخرى من
العالم خاصه ان
السودان تمثل اهميه استراتيجيه حقيقه وان
السودان كغيرها من المناطق الحيويه تمثل
احد ساحات الصراع الاستراتيجي الدولي
المرتبطه بالصراع الحالي في النظام الدولي
ما بين القوى الكبرى ولا يتخذ من مناطق
مختلفه رايناها في دول كثيره وبالتالي
سيكون السودان هنا سيدفع ثمن ثمه بالاساس
الشعب السوداني ازمه الاقتصاديه الاوضاع
لان السؤال هل سيتحمل الشعب السوداني ان
تضاف ازمه جديده ان هذا الازمه العسكريه
وحاله الانغلاق وكل هذا اضافه الازمه
الاقتصاديه الطحنه الى متى هل سيشكل الشعب
السوداني احد العمله الضاغطه على كل على
الجانبين اللي هي الدفع نحو الاقل وقف
اطلاق النار وحقن الدماء وتجميد الوضع ام
ستظل الامور باتجاه اخر في المقابل هل ما
هي طبيعه الضغوط الدوليه والخارجيه هل
ستدفع الطرفي الصراع الى على الاقل
التجميد ام سيتجه الى مزيد من الاستقواء
بالخارج او استقرار باطراف خارجيه نحن
حقيقه امام حاله يعني حاله ربما يشهد
تكرارها في سنرال سابقه ولذلك هنا الحكمه
تقول ان التدخل الخارجي سيكون سلبيا سيعني
استمرار الازمه العسكريه من الخطوره كانت
الازمه السياسيه مستمره وكان هناك نوع من
التحمل لهذه الازمه ايضا الازمه
الاقتصاديه على الاقل كان هناك حد من
التحمل لكن الازمه العسكريه واستمرارها قد
تتسع وبالتالي لن يكون في مقدار السودان
التحمل هذه الازمه وهذا يكون لسانوريوهات
لا نتمناها للسودان الشقيق الباحث السياسي
الدكتور احمد سيد احمد من القاهره شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه شكرا ايضا
للبحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع الدكتور رياض
القهوجي كنت معي هنا في الاستوديو اعزائي
المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره مستمر
يصحبكم في الساعه المقبله من هذه التغطيه
الزميل نايف الاحمري من الرياض وانا
القاكم في تمام
الخامسه اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات